get to the microwave and as few steps as
possible open the door before the
microwave dings fewer steps wins there
are five minutes on the clock the
microwave starts now
where's the microwave
where's that my inside have you seen a
microwave no in the shed yeah fewest
steps
dammit I structured the wording in such
a way that there would be no possibility
of people just you know taking steps no
I mean these are clever people no one's
just gonna take big steps no turn to see
Dylan yes okay - maybe hopping is better
[Applause]
19:3 one way to 2326 - so
[Music]
a potato is that it yeah when you go
here very quickly you thought about it
for eight seconds which is longer than
usual with the big steps so use them you
go there in 30 seconds and you only took
29 steps so I mean it's the lowest so
far we're gonna see if somebody can come
up with a different way shall we look
wrong and Freddie you live there when is
this a step that's not really a step is
it that's just crawling crawl it there's
nothing counting steps right so so I
feel like there are no steps involved in
this
not great for the knees I'll tell you
that I gotta wear
[Music]
okay that's work hopefully Ron all right
that's your day going so far so good for
me right just in time
hey thanks Ron thank you